i'm announcing today the new jobs
support scheme the government will
directly support the wages of people
in work giving businesses who face
depressed demand
the option of keeping employees in a job
on shorter hours rather than making them
redundant the job support scheme is
built on three principles
first it will support viable jobs
to make sure of that employees must work
at least a third of their normal hours
and be paid for that work as normal by
their employer
the government together with employers
will then increase those people's wages
covering two-thirds of the pay they have
lost
by reducing their working hours and the
employee
will keep their job second
we will target support at firms who need
it the most
all small and medium-sized businesses
are eligible
but larger businesses only when their
turnover has fallen
through the crisis third it will be open
to employers across the united
kingdom even if they have not previously
used
the furlough scheme the scheme will run
for six months
starting in november and employers
retaining
furloughed staff on shorter hours can
claim both
the job support scheme and the jobs
retention bonus mr speaker
throughout this crisis we have sought
parity between employees
and the self-employed providing more
than 13 billion pounds of support
to over 2.6 million self-employed
small businesses so i am extending the
existing
self-employed grant on similar terms and
conditions
as the new jobs support scheme
mr speaker these are radical
interventions
in the uk labor market policies we have
never tried in this country
before together with the jobs retention
bonus
the kickstart scheme for young people
tens of billions of pounds of job
creation schemes
new investment in training and
apprenticeships we
are protecting millions of jobs and
businesses
mr speaker if we want to protect jobs
this winter
the second major challenge is helping
businesses
with cash flow over the last six months
we've supported business with tens of
billions of pounds
of tax deferrals and generous
government-backed
loans those policies have been
a lifeline but right now businesses need
every extra pound
to protect jobs rather than repaying
loans
and tax deferrals so i'm taking
four further steps today to make that
happen
first bounce back loans have given over
a
million small businesses a 38 billion
pound boost
to survive this pandemic to give those
businesses
more time and greater flexibility to
repay their loans
we are introducing pay as you grow
this means loans can now be extended
from
6 to 10 years nearly halving
the average monthly repayment businesses
who are struggling
can now choose to make interest-only
payments
and anyone in real trouble can apply to
suspend repayments
altogether for up to six months
no business taking up pay as you grow
will see their credit rating
affected as a result
second i am also changing the terms of
our other loan schemes
more than sixty thousand small and
medium-sized businesses
have now taken out coronavirus business
interruption loans
to help them i plan to extend the
government guarantee on these loans
for up to 10 years making it easier for
lenders
to give more people more time to repay
i am also extending the deadline of all
our loan schemes
to the end of this year and we are
starting work on a new
successor loan guarantee program set to
begin
in january third i want to give
businesses
more time and flexibility over their
deferred tax bills
nearly half a million businesses
deferred more than 30
billion pounds of vat this year
on current plans those payments fall due
in march instead i will allow businesses
to spread that vat bill over 11
smaller repayments with no interest to
pay
and any of the millions of self-assessed
income taxpayers who need extra help
can also now extend their outstanding
tax bill
over 12 months from next january
the final step i'm taking today will
support two
of the most affected sectors hospitality
and tourism on current plans
their vat rates will increase from five
percent
back to the standard rate of twenty
percent on january
the thirteenth so to support more than a
hundred and fifty thousand businesses
and help protect two point four million
jobs through the winter
i'm announcing today that we are
cancelling the planned increase
and will keep the lower five percent vat
rate until march the 31st
next year
mr speaker today's measures mark
an important evolution in our approach
our lives can no longer be put on hold
since may we have taken steps to
liberate our economy
and society we did these things
because life means more than simply
existing
we find meaning and hope through our
friends and family
through our work through our community
people were not wrong for wanting that
meaning
for striving towards normality and nor
was the government wrong to want this
for them
i said in the summer that we must endure
and live with the uncertainty
of the moment this means learning our
new limits
as we go because the truth is the
responsibility
for defeating coronavirus cannot be held
by government alone it is a collective
responsibility
shared by all because the cost
is paid by all we have so often spoken
about this virus
in terms of lives lost
but the price our country is paying is
wider than that
the government has done much to mitigate
the effects
of these awful trade-offs between health
education
and employment and as we think about the
next few weeks
and months we need to bear all of those
costs
in mind as such it would be dishonest to
say
there is now some risk-free solution or
that we can mandate behavior to such an
extent we lose
any sense of personal responsibility
what was true
at the beginning of this crisis remains
true now
it's on all of us and we must learn to
live with it and live
without fear